27 mai prochain nous présenterons au
président de la république
un décret qui appellera les électeurs à
se rendre aux urnes pour le second tour
des élections municipales le 28 juin
prochain les électeurs de nouvelle
calédonie et de polynésie française
seront également convoqué à cette même
date pour le second tour des élections
municipales
ce ne sera pas un second tour comme
avant si j'ose dire avec les maires qui
organise le scrutin avec les candidats
et leurs équipes de campagne
nous avons la double responsabilité
d'assurer à la fois la sécurité de ceux
qui participent au processus électoral
et la sincérité du scrutin
comme nous l'avions déjà fait pour le
premier tour le ministre de l'intérieur
va engager dès la semaine prochaine la
concertation avec les maires de france
pour organiser en toute sûreté
les opérations électorales proprement
dit en suivant précisément les
recommandations du conseil scientifique
le ministre de l'intérieur va également
poursuivre la concertation avec les
organisations politiques pour adapter la
campagne à la situation sanitaire
la sincérité du scrutin donc le bon
déroulement de la campagne sont des
conditions sine qua none au bon
fonctionnement d'une démocratie
si cette concertation fait apparaître
qu'il est nécessaire de faire évoluer
telle ou telle disposition réglementaire
nous pourrons le faire
je pense notamment à l'assouplissement
des règles relatives aux procurations
cohérence encore comme toutes les
décisions prises dans le cadre du
déconfinement celle de tenir le second
tour des élections le 28 juin prochain
est réversible
nous aurons donc comme le recommande
d'ailleurs le conseil scientifique et
comme toutes les forces politiques l'ont
souligné
une clause de revoyure elle interviendra
sans doute dans deux semaines en effet
dans l'hypothèse où ce second tour ne
pourrait pas avoir lieu
il faudrait garder le temps nécessaire à
l'examen par le parlement du cadre légal
qui permettrait d'organiser un nouveau
report
ici c'est la raison pour laquelle et
j'ai conscience d'entrer dans des
considérations très juridique
c'est la raison pour laquelle sera
également présenté en quelque sorte à
titre conservatoire le 27 mai prochain
au conseil des ministres un projet de
loi qui permettrait le report des
municipales au plus tard jusqu'en
janvier 2021
dans l'hypothèse où le conseil
scientifique nous dirait dans deux
semaines que les conditions sanitaires
ne seraient plus réunies pour le 28